emails are a continuing revelation in a
series of revelations that have come out
slowly in the past year and a half that
indicate what appears to be a concerted
effort to construct a narrative I am
Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and today
we're talking with cheryl atkinson she's
the award-winning journalist who
recently parted ways with CBS after the
press said it was due to friction
between her and her bosses at CBS and
the her investigations and things like
Benghazi Fast and the Furious in other
cases Sheryl thanks for joining us
thanks for having me
you at your web site at Charlotte
concern comm you say your credo is that
you're resisting undue corporate
political and other special interests
and you're the author of the forthcoming
book it'll be coming out in the fall
stonewalled my fight for the truth
against the forces of obstruction
intimidation and harassment in Obama's
Washington talk a little bit about
Benghazi because this was the story that
you're probably best known for at this
point in time and it certainly caused a
lot of controversy we've just learned
that in fact the White House did have
emails where they were pushing Susan
Rice and other people who are talking
about Benghazi very early on to stress
that this was in the quote of Ben Rhodes
the guy behind this email that Susan
Rice and others should underscore that
these protests at the Benghazi compound
are rooted in the innocence of Muslims
video and not a broader failure of
policy is this a vindicate a vindication
of the coverage that you were working on
well I would I would start by saying to
the extent that anyone has believed that
covering Benghazi is a legitimate news
story is a controversial thing to do
it's kind of what I'm writing the book
about there's there's an effort to
controversial eyes reporting that can be
damaging to certain interests and it's
their effort to make it appear as though
very legitimate lines of criticism and
fair reporting are in fact somehow
controversial and by saying it often
enough I think they've convinced people
that in fact it is so I mean what you're
saying is that even to get to a point
where you know
when you say okay well let's find out
what actually happened up in Gaza what
were the steps leading up to it and
leading away from it you've been told
again and again or people you know in
the Obama administration and some people
who are sympathetic to them and the
presser saying look there's nothing to
discuss here the only reason you're
interested in covering this is because
you have an agenda or a vendetta against
them and I think that's a well
orchestrated strategy that it's somewhat
successful but it's pretty easy to see
through if you analyze it I would say
the groups that have tried to
controversial eyes my reporting let's
look at some of this the main stories
fast and furious as you said Benghazi
and my green energy debacle stories all
three of them by neutral peer group were
nominated or received any awards on a
national basis those are not partisan
journalists who award those things so
you can either listen to sort of neutral
news reporting which is what I do or you
can listen to those who are accused of
mismanagement and wrongdoing who say of
course that the reporting is inaccurate
let's talk first about Benghazi and the
emails does does it surprise you that
these are emails which the Congress
actually the Oversight Committee and
Congress asked for these emails they
subpoena them they were not able to get
them they came to light through a
lawsuit being brought by Judicial Watch
which is a far-right or you know
antagonistic to democratic nonprofit
group so it came out do these emails
show that the White House was has been
acting dodgy about just the events
leading up to and away from bingo well
the White House has not been forthcoming
with the information we've asked about
about this issue and I too have
requested those documents under Freedom
of Information over a year ago and have
not received them even though under the
law they're required to provide them to
me as they provided them to digital
watch they haven't yet but yes the
emails are a continuing revelation in a
series of revelations that have come out
slowly in the past year and a half that
indicate what appears to be a concerted
effort to construct a narrative I think
it was pretty obvious early on that this
was happening based on documents of
witness testimony so I think this just
adds a little more meat to it what is
then there I mean is the narrative
clearly it's a scandal
you know or it it's not even a scandal
it's a tragedy that you know a number of
US personnel including the ambassador to
a newly liberated Libya were killed
clearly a failure of policy
implementation of security procedures of
nation-building or whatever I mean you
know it's just failure all the way
around why are they trying you know what
are they trying to do to keep people
from asking and you know getting answers
to legitimate questions of like why did
this happen I think like any government
that may be facing criticism especially
eight weeks before a presidential
election this was crucial and could have
been devastating to them if we knew
everything now then that we know now
like one week after it happened I think
that really would have been devastating
to the campaign but I think the primary
goal for any political group that is in
a position like this would be to delay
the release as long as possible of the
damaging details which they've
effectively done in many cases and as
they dribble out slowly they begin to
say well now it's old news and who cares
and they've had time to try to
politicize and controversial eyes the
reporting which all serves the purpose I
guess the initial goal and I guess you
know to move into fast and furious this
is another story that you effectively
broke which was seen as potentially very
damaging to the Obama administration who
tried to say oh now this didn't happen
or we had no knowledge of it or that it
was a holdover from the Bush
administration can you recap for us just
briefly what fast and furious was about
fast and furious was an effort when I
first began covering the story we
thought perhaps even a small local
effort misguided on the part of federal
officials from the alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms federal agency to catch
criminals and Mexican cartel lords in
Mexico by doing the unthinkable which is
letting guns through traffickers fall
into the hands of the cartels and see
where they end up with the idea that
then we can catch the major cartel you
know kingpin and and this will be better
because we can prove that guns come from
the United States and arm the cartels in
fact it turned out to be something much
bigger than Phoenix there were many
operations with different names that
were happening simultaneously in other
states the this is a wonderful lesson
and
why not to initially believe the
government's proclamations about things
without checking yourself because
initially the government story evolved
from you know this never happened the
whistleblowers are lying which was you
know proven false then they said well it
was isolated to Phoenix Arizona which
was false then they admitted okay ATF
headquarters in DC knew about it but
nobody at justice knew of the case which
turned out to be false then Justice
Department said well we had some
knowledge but nobody at the White House
knew of the case which turned out to be
false and then the president declared
executive privilege so that we can't see
those final document why is it that you
know people you know this this stoked
the imagination of the of the right and
of Obama critics why do you think it did
not catch on bigger in the in the
American population is it that the story
doesn't matter it's too confusing or
that the the administration's kind of
slow drip you know strategy actually
worked I do know at the time when I was
starting to cover it that other
reporters were also trying to cover the
story and that they were being prevented
from their editorial bosses the stories
are being prevented from airing so
sometimes the ground-level reporters do
want to cover these stories but you have
to get past other hurdles and there are
managers if they don't see it as a story
or they want to block the story it won't
get published so I think because it
wasn't widely published first of all it
didn't catch on I was you know I and I
guess Fox News and a few other outlets
were covering it and then it was
successfully fairly politicized even
though it was revealed that the
government had in fact not been telling
the truth about it by the time all of
that came out it was have been portrayed
as a Republican versus Democrat
controversy so half the people didn't
care and the other half thought maybe it
was political you know and we're hearing
rain now because of our poorly insulated
studios so if if people hear a drumbeat
that's what it is you know what happened
to journalists you know I checked on
Wikipedia and I won't I won't reveal
your age and I also won't reveal that
you're actually the creator of Bitcoin
but Europe you're around my age I know
that when I got into journalism part of
the whole thing was that you wanted to
street speak truth to power you know it
was very much watching at least the
movie for
of all the president's men you're you
were saying that reporters in our not
even reporters but editors and the
people who call shots in major media
outlets what happened to them that they
no longer when they see a government
lying to its people in a in a pattern
systematic way and they're saying now
they really don't cover that that
wouldn't be of interest that wouldn't be
good you know what's what's going on in
American news right I think it's a
complex set of factors and if you try to
give one explanation you can find an
exception to it that disproves it so it
it's a little bit of a generalization
that I'll make but I'll say yes there
are some ideological forces at play but
yes there are also competing pressures
not to offend certain corporate
interests and also our corporate
managers are tied into both corporations
and politicians it's all to me it's
become almost all one of the same the
interests of the government the
interests of corporations and the
interests of the news media have kind of
melded together whereby I think in many
instances the news media is not doing
that good old government watchdog job
that goes to do can I ask is this I mean
you worked at CBS News CBS has been a
major corporation that had you know I
mean they used to in the New York
Yankees for God's sake this is a very
diversified company which itself can be
owned by other people etc has it really
changed or like what what is going on
because why why should we look back 20
or 30 years and say we're 40 years and
say CBS would have been more independent
then because it was still a giant
corporation that was going to be going
to the government to say hey you know we
need this FCC license or this ruling or
could you help us out on this what
what's changing that if your thesis is
correct that the corporations and the
news media corporations corporate
interests and political interests are
tighter now but what's happened I can't
explain why in the past two to three
years especially that I've noticed it
more its but it's impacted I believe my
work more so there have always been
challenges along the way there are
challenges in every newsroom there are
competing interests of competing
pressures but those have traditionally
been fairly navigable overall something
different is happening and I can tell
you I just returned from an
investigative reporting conference
in Berkeley California where top
Pulitzer Prize winning journalists were
all making the same observations as we
are from the New York Times and formerly
LA Times and Washington Post and very
prestigious and well-respected outlets
have all said there's something
happening now I think the New York Times
James risin or Lowell Bergman who's
another independent journalist said they
called it a fundamental change in
society and they blamed they said maybe
it started prior to the Obama
administration but has continued during
the Obama administration and gotten
worse and the journalists they say
basically need to as you said you know
speak to the power and and do something
about it because this is in their view
unprecedented are they I mean but how
about that I mean you say over the past
couple of years it's gotten particularly
worse how much of this could we just say
is that you know it so for a long time
it's been that particularly mainstream
large circulation newspapers in DC and
New Yorker media outlets you know they
tend to be democratic they tend to be
liberal Democrats they loved Obama I
mean this is it was on a bash for a lot
of reasons is it just that they are
covering their guy you know they're
they're throwing themselves on him to
save him in a way that they wouldn't do
that with george w bush a piece of the
puzzle i think is the idea that many
people hoped this president would be
different in terms of transparency and
openness with the press i think they
gave him the benefit of the doubt and
then some hoping that it would change
and felt some people i think are so
ideologically entrenched that it
outweighs their journalism instincts and
they hope against hope that this is
something good for the country and they
don't want to be part of what they see
is an effort or a vehicle that that
fights that i think there's somebody but
you're also saying it's not the whole of
the story in that when obama is gone
we're still going to be faced with this
kind of interlocking Directorate of
corporate power and political power as
one whistleblower put it to me a
government whistleblower things have
never been worse for the people that try
to speak the truth inside the government
about illegalities and wrongdoing and in
their view and I tend to agree every
administration is perhaps a little bit
more clamped down and
than the one before it and the next one
starts from that finishing point it's
very hard to make it go backwards there
are rules being instituted now against
journalists and the type of work that we
do that I think will be very hard to
unwind can you give an example of that
there was a I guess a rule passed this
week and I didn't research it it was
announced at the investigative reporting
conference so if I'm not relaying it
exactly correctly forgive me but it's
about apparently James clapper has
instituted a new rule that makes it
illegal for anyone in the intelligence
agencies to speak to reporters about
anything that's how it was described to
us which is is hugely restrictive and
way more so than anything that had been
done in the past which means the very
guy who did not tell the truth to
Congress a few months back when asked or
maybe it was last year about these
surveillance programs has since been put
in charge of fixing the problem the
government's overreach and he's doing so
by overreaching even further into you
know people's rights to to speak about
what's going on now you know you paint a
dark picture isn't it also true though
that you know with the rise of groups
like anonymous WikiLeaks the Edward
Snowden revelations independent
journalism whether it's things like Vox
or things like you know that the new
project that Glenn Greenwald and others
have done it with the with money from
the eBay fortune
is it is it also simultaneous says the
government is clamping down more they're
doing that partly because more and more
stuff is getting out and do you see is
it is it a bright light or a dim light
of kind of truly independent journalism
that goes outside of you know major
outlets like the New York Times or The
Washington Post or the CBS News well I
think that remains to be seen the
problem with relying on independent
outlets and blogs and alternative news
sites is they have very little clout and
the government has systematically been
in my opinion instituting rules and
policies that closed down legitimate
press inquiry and basically replacing
that with their own propaganda machines
and you know at some point that becomes
fairly insurmountable no matter how in
Penant you are and how much you try to
dig if they've been able to control
access to such a degree that the
mainstream press I couldn't get into
certain government buildings to cover
stories because I think unfairly and
perhaps unlawfully they banned me or for
reasons that could be challenged in
court they banned me but if we don't
challenge those rules and policies and
they become codified what what chance
does a an independent blogger stand of
getting access to the things that that
he needs let's talk a little bit about
your politics because once you became
more critical of the Obama
administration or you know which also on
a certain level makes sense that you
know if you're covering the White House
or you're covering big stories of the
day it's always going to be the person
occupying the White House but you were
talked about as you know you would you
were a hyper conservative you were a
secret Republican etc I mean the fact of
the matter is is you've also reported
stories that are pretty damaging to the
Republican Party and one that maybe we
can talk a little bit about is the way
that a series of freshman GOP members
who were tea party favor - had pledged
not to hang out with special interests
and what I went on a kind of
all-expenses-paid junket to talk to
lobbyists can you talk a little bit
about that sort well we got a tip and we
found a way to get access to this group
of freshman Republicans who went to a
fundraising event down in Key Largo
Florida that seemed to be giving you
know extremely special access to
lobbyists and other interests sometimes
it was theorized on committees on which
they said I don't know if a lot of
people know now the congressional
committees in my view based on my
experience instead of overseeing some of
the industries that they're supposed to
oversee use those positions to get
donations from those industries to
basically not oversee them so it's kind
of this upside-down world so we did
confirm they wouldn't let us know the
names of the people who attended this
event but we we know there was at least
one banking lobbyists and some of these
members sit on the banking committee so
it was just an example of the appearance
of politicians saying one thing and
doing quite another one
and there was nothing illegal you know
as far as that you could ascertain going
on I mean this was a legitimate
fundraising thing but it's it's a case
in point of political hitaka it's a kind
of secret access that people with money
and power get that ordinary people can't
get from members of Congress that's the
example when is your book going to be
coming up it should be coming out of
November if the schedule stays put
okay thank you cheryl atkinson
protecting a recent TV about power you
know political power corporate power
economic power and media power and
whether or not that shrinking or not
Thanks for recent TV I'm Nikolas Lee